you nate silver state schools credit
union is back to share how they're
helping your credit
and your community at the same time take
a look here you guys are adding
value to your members and how absolutely
so silver state schools credit union is
a member-owned full-service
financial institution we serve the las
vegas valley with over 10 branch
locations and we serve over 55 000
members by the way
so think of us as even as a big bank we
do
everything we offer a full suite of
banking products financial solutions
and excellent member service to boot
awesome you guys are giving back to your
members but also back to the community
how are you guys doing that
absolutely so just one example is we
partner with several
organizations in southern nevada they
share our common value of giving back to
the community and
one of the ex current examples of that
is littering lights
where families are able to drive through
and enjoy those thousands of holiday
lights and shut
and stop at the silver state schools uh
credit union sponsored
santa selfie selfie station which is
kind of a cool thing
that we've had to do as kind of an
adjustment to the pandemic this year so
um so the glittering lights opened this
last friday november 13th and it
actually runs all the way through
january 10th
and so anyone's also welcome to visit
one of our 10 branch locations
and get actually a five dollar off
coupon and you know it's just a great
way to bring back some normalcy to our
lives
especially during these difficult times
and also to kick off the holiday season
i was going to say especially during the
holidays when we're trying to feel
like it's the holidays right have any
special promotions going on
yeah as a matter of fact right now we've
got a great auto refinance
promotion and we're running that through
the end of december
it's a great opportunity for our members
and future members to actually save
money
on for what matters most you can find
details online at silverstatecu.com
what we call abc or a better car loan
it's an auto finance that also offers a
90
data first payment option and helps you
save additional cash during the holiday
season
and don't be surprised if you can reduce
your rate too
well it can't get any better than that
yeah exactly
the most important question is how can
people become members of your credit
union
yep i'm glad you asked that's that's
always important so
volunteers students retirees or parents
um
and garden actually even guardians of a
student
involved in an educational organization
in nevada can all be members of silver
state schools credit union
and you can also join silver state
schools credit union by making a
one-time
donation to vegas pbs which greatly
supports the las vegas and nevada
education communities something to
remember they're offering a special auto
refinance campaign through the end of
december so just call 702-733-8820
or visit that website right there on
your screen we'll be right back